Shalom Roy Moore here with a message for  the Jewish community of Alabama I know  some of you were offended by what my  wife Kayla said last night  one of our attorneys is it you but I  want you to know that I believe Jewish  people are so much more than just  attorneys they can also be accountants  or Seinfeld writers my dry cleaner is  responsible for many great cultural  achievements in our society the old  testament which provided the ten  commandments you invented Chinese food  and you gave us the world's hardest  elderly woman kalgard Oh vote for me  today and when I redesign the Alabama  state flag I promise to include a Jewish  star I love Jewish people I can't  imagine life without in fact the one  person who has inspired my life the most  is Jewish that's right  Woody Allen thanks a lot lower more  mints for sinners if the kyai or  I doubt it no no  you